tonight it's Doug's turn to take over
this competition I'm so excited about
this man
bladesmiths
two versions of the same blade
One winner
forged in fire weapons Showdown
oh boy it's Miss congratulations you
guys are gonna have four days to build
yet another weapon from the mind of Doug
marcaida
latesmans I want you to build this
a super-sized cortada sword
look at that
blade must pass three tests
the sharpness test the strength test the
kill test gentlemen good luck see you in
four days
coming in hot my name is Jason Coy
biggest challenge today is going to get
that Damascus Billet all forged up and
ready to go and make sure the forge
welds are solid we're good
so I have this blade ready for clinch
nerve-wracking I'm ready to do it about
to become a blade
she's straight
we got a blade we need to finish
grinding the blade and get that all
ready to go and then start working on
the handle
looking good I'm really happy with how
this is coming together on the fit and
finish feels good in my hands I'm gonna
get an edge on this thing I've got a
little bit of time left here and I'm
getting this blade nice and sharp I want
to test it on some wood just to make
sure it's a high quality blade
the blade performed great Edge held up
no damage I know Trinity is going to
bring it so I know it's going to be
close all done man
I'm Trinity Trout from Pueblo Colorado
and I'm a part-time placement I want to
weld it up and get it ready for the
forge
today we're going to build multi-layer
Damascus Billet when we're done with
this it's going to have a design in it
that's going to set it off we did a
Quench and we did a temper yesterday
it's looking good so far today the
biggest challenge is to make sure that
you get good clean bevels round into the
sword and make sure that I make it to
the acetate by the end of the day on a
blade like this we have real pronounced
clean bevels that are expected as part
of the parameters
got a good medium pitch Edge on the
blade and it's sharp at the same time
but durable
um I'll be working on the other
components of other blade
I need to finalize the handle profile
get it all centered up nice and smooth
and then assembly
getting ready to pour silver onto the
handle kind of made a silver end cap and
a silver collar
and that really set off the handle
what the hell just beat the hell out of
it
all right Jason let's talk about your
weapon here your edges are very sharp
the slices are clean you cut the ties in
half well we're all sir your cortada it
will cut thanks sir
all right Trinity let's talk about your
edge here you have a more obtuse grind
on this Edge compared to the other one
but it does cut some of the pieces over
here an overall sir
it will cut
foreign
Jason first off your handle is
absolutely perfect for my hand your
blade it's as straight as when I started
everything's right and tight and Edge no
damage at all good job thanks sir
all right Trinity first off Blade's
still straight
your Edge didn't take any damage at all
your handle construction is really
smooth but one of the times that I hit
that blade it did a little bit of a
rotate in my hand
but everything's held up beautifully
nicely done thank you sir
all right Jason's talking about your
super sized cortada sword here it cuts
deep when I'm slashing with it the
double edge pierces nicely cuts on the
way out and it is fun to wield overall
sir this cortada sword it will kill
all right you need to talk about your
super sized cortada sword here first up
the design you have Cuts deep into this
ballistic zummy the double edge cuts on
the way out your handle Kit's got a
belly there it's got the flare that I
want overall sir your curtara it will
heal very nice
oh boys Miss I want to say
congratulations both of you guys I
haven't seen blades this beautiful
perform as well as yours did in a long
time so you both have a ton to be proud
of but in this competition only one of
you is leaving here with the title of
Fortune fire champion and a check for
ten thousand dollars the judges have
deliberated and they made their decision
today's Forge of fire Champion is
Jason congratulations man
well Trinity it's been an honor to watch
you work you are clearly an extremely
talented Smith and honestly in almost
any other competition you'd be going
home with the win but the competition
was extremely Fierce this time and at
this point I'm gonna have to ask you to
please step off the forge floor Roger
that
I felt like I did well but I would have
spent a little bit more time on the edge
obviously the hardest part was the time
management for sure well I didn't win
today but it was a great experience
overall and I'm happy for it
well Jason congratulations that
for ten thousand dollars congratulations
thank you thank you one Fortune fire I
knew it was going to be neck and neck
and I knew Trinity was going to bring an
awesome blade he did
it's Jason Coy I'm the fortune fire
Champion glory to God forged in fire
weapon Showdown